ROOKER OF THE YEAR
MARVEL'S GUARDIANS OF THE GALAXY
WILL BE IN THEATERS ON
AUGUST 1ST.
I'VE SEEN IT, IT IS AMAZING. YOU
SHOULD SEE IT TOO IF YOU LIKE
AWESOME THINGS.
ONE OF THE STARS IS IN OUR
STUDIO RIGHT NOW.
PLEASE WELCOME MICHAEL ROOKER!
>> HEY!
>> HEY, BUDDY. HOW ARE YOU?
>> Chris: NOW IN THE FILM YOU
PLAY YONDU, A BLUE SKINNED ALIEN
WARRIOR. HERE YOU ARE, THAT'S
YOUR CHARACTER.
>> I AM LOOKING PRETTY HOT.
>> YOU LOOK LIKE A SKIN HEAD
SMURF.
>> I LOOK LIKE I HAVE
CONSTIPATION ACTUALLY.
>> Chris: YOU HAVE A LONG
CAREER PLAYING TOUGH GUYS AND
LAW GUYS WITH BADASS NAMES. LIKE
IN WALKING DEAD YOU WERE MERLE
DIXON. YOU OLD BROTHER MERLE.
>> YEP. YOU KNOW WHAT, I'VE BEEN
TYPE-CAST A LOT OVER THE YEARS,
LIKE ROWDY BURNS, DAYS OF
THUNDER.
>> EZ PONDER, STAN "ZEEDO"
ZEDKOV.
>> THESE NAMES ARE ALL GREAT BUT
I FEEL LIKE I WANT THE COMEDIANS
TO COME UP WITH MORE TOUGH GUY
NAMES FOR MICHAEL ROOKER TO
PLAY. HE'S STANDING RIGHT HERE
IN THE GAME, SO HE'S GOING TO BE
JUDGING YOU AS WELL. I'M GONNA
PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK.
THE MORE RIDICULOUS THE NAME,
THE BETTER, GO. JOE.
BEEF STEW.
YEAH. BEEF STEW, EXCELLENT.
POINTS. NIKKI.
>> BLAKE WHORESBREATH.
>> BAM, BABY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JOE.
>> DENIRO PACINO.
>> YEAH POINTS. EXCELLENT. PHIL.
>> ROSIE O'DONNELL.
>> Chris: POINTS. NIKKI
>> DAVE CAR-SPORTS-TITS-GUNS
>> Chris: POINTS. YEAH PHIL.
>> WILLY MAMMOTH.
>> Chris: YEAH, WILLY MAMMOTH.
POINTS.
>> YEAH, I LIKE THAT.
NIKKI.
>> BORIS WOLFCOCK.
>> OH, THAT'S THE BEST YET.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Chris: POINTS. PHIL
>> TAINT (BLEEP)FISTER.
>> Chris: PRETTY TOUGH NAME.
OKAY. POINTS.
>> POINTS, JOE.
>> MAJOR VOLTAGE.
>> Chris: OH.
POINTS.
YES.
JOE AGAIN.
>> BIG DICK MURRAY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MICHAEL ROOKER, EVERYBODY!
>> THANK YOU!